i will show you okay what can i can i do
it along with you
yes yes of course and you can yeah
you guys want to do it yes yes tell me
how you feel afterwards
okay we just do one round i recommend
you do it uh jordan you do it whenever
you feel anxiety or uh deep
neurological deficiency or whatever
yes okay well that means i should be
doing it about two or three hundred
times a day
i would say i i think if you do this
then it it's like staying away along a
longer and longer time
but let's do it okay
okay here we are relaxed
take a deep breath
all in and let it go
all in
let it go
i will take the telephone then see how
long
you're going to stay first round 90
seconds
one half minute after the exhalation
without uh without air in the lungs
for 90 seconds no force
that is deeply into the neurology you
will see
just follow me and i will show you here
on the timer that you do so
and i will talk while well and and
say what is happening because you feel
it okay
all right there we go
this by the way this technique uh with
this
weeb uh change fundamentally
uh medical sides of our perspective
of what we can do within our
physiological depth
against bacteria virus depression
neurological diseases etc
but now you will experience so
i will show the on the camera the the
numbers
oh god i don't know if i can do that
there we go so now you got it
fully in let it go
fully in
let it go
pull in
let it go keep on going the mind goes
with the breath
don't mind about nothing else but your
breath
the mind is a big player so let it be
with the breath
julian
let it go
pull in let it go
keep on going fully in
let it go become light-headed go
on fully in let it go
18 times more fully in
let it go
fully
letting go 13 become lightheaded
loom in the body don't mind just go
it takes just a couple of minutes what
we do
to arrive at a deep impact on our
physiology
deeper than in science was thought
possible it's all here then after
the feeling because feeling is
understanding
we can talk
eight more just go it's a workout
stab it let it go
in let
letting go now now comes the last one
juliet let it go
and stop after the exhalation
close your mouth no smuggling
just witness there is no need for
breathing
the carbon dioxide has been blown off ph
level uh
is a really high there is no trigger to
breathe
only the brain could reflex but don't
just be in the peace it's the
parasympathetic nervous system
deep peace no need for breathing
just witness you're deep into the
physiology of your being
the way nature meant to be because you
are right now
in deep deep stress but you are tranquil
it's a paradox we are really deep
into our physiology right now no force
and you changed your biochemistry
and now the adrenal axis is
shooting out through all the body
resets the body any defect
is being neutralized getting rid off
10 seconds small
nine six
three two one
fully it fully in and hold
fully and hold squeeze it to your head
three two one
let it go there we are
god i hated that yeah sure
but this is the way we you know what you
hit more
this neurological defect yes and this is
the way
through deep stress activated
consciously
while being okay because it's
maybe also because of the stress of the
podcast
and so yeah did we hold our breath for
90 seconds
you could yes for 90 seconds you guys
did 90 seconds
here it's all there i probably did 85
seconds and took a tiny little breath
yeah that's what happened to me too
this is round number one right number
two we would go two minutes
round number three two and a half number
four three minutes of holding back
exhale
into lungs yes you have you gotta do
this then
you will see how how do you feel
well i'm not wandering around the room
uncontrollably moving and screaming so
you know that's better than three or
four hours of my day
i'm still able to stay calm and sit here
and talk to you
exactly that's an accomplishment now you
got to go
even deeper and so in four rounds you
will be able to reach
after exhalation that is there is a
understanding principle
after exhalation means there is no air
anymore in the lungs
and you exhale completely yeah almost
completely
like i found i found if you if you
exhale all the way and then you kind of
bring your stomach
up underneath your ribs yes
um that helps i got taught that earlier
this year it kind of helps
in yoga that is the contraction udiyana
bunda
it's all you know it's all knowledge
but this is all new and that it is true
science makes it trust worthy
it's data it shows that we are
activating the immune system
through this deep stress the adrenal
axis suddenly spikes while you are in
control
how many breaths did you have us take
about 30
30 30 breaths and then a minute and then
and so with your with your your advice
is to do the 30 breaths and the 90
minutes of breath holding 90 seconds
90 seconds of breath holding yes around
that
and then what i advise is this
go without force